una nueva pesadilla para boris johnson
el primer ministro británico vivió una
rebelión interna y necesitó del apoyo de
los laboristas para aprobar la
obligatoriedad de un certificado para
acceder a discotecas y eventos masivos
por mucho que queramos que la gente se
vacune no queremos una sociedad en la
que se pidan papeles y se prive a las
personas de su libertad también logró
aprobar la vacunación obligatoria para
el personal de salud en 2022 y re
imponer mascarillas en interiores
mientras las autoridades calculan que
reinó unido- estaría registrando 200.000
casos diarios con la variante omicron
disparada francia se plantea aumentar
las medidas restrictivas con reino unido
y
seguimos buscando cómo podemos reforzar
las reglas en la frontera de
protección ante el temor de la
propagación de omicron que llega hasta
italia donde han reactivado la
obligación de presentar una prueba
negativa a todos los vecinos de la unión
europea hasta el 31 de enero
de la protección externa a la interna en
países bajos se extendió hasta después
de navidad del confinamiento nocturno a
las 5 de la tarde mientras que los
colegios cerrarán entre el 20 y el 21 de
diciembre adelantando una semana las
vacaciones y limitando las reuniones
navideñas a cuatro personas
tendencias europeas del control del
virus que también llegan hasta américa
este martes entró en vigor en colombia
la exigencia de que todo viajero
internacional debe entrar con la pauta
completa de vacunación se trata de una
tendencia en la vacunación cada vez más
extendida como también demuestra la
fuerza armada estadounidense que
despidió a 27 soldados que se habrían
negado a ser inoculados